whiplash finally for goodness sakes
finally I am so sick of these limited
release movies everyone's telling me to
see taking like a month to come to Ohio
but it finally did so I got to see
whiplash stars miles teller and JK
Simmons miles teller plays a drummer but
not just any drummer he wants to be the
next great and JK Simmons plays a well
respected music talent teacher coach
scout slash really mean guy he hears
miles teller playing one day and decide
you know what come into my class one
time and then he just starts grilling
miles Taylor's character I'm talking
devouring him in every sense of the word
until he can't take it anymore and a
psychological battle of wits begins I
remember the first time I really took
note of miles teller and that was in the
American remake of Footloose and it
wasn't a good note that I took he just
seemed like the guy who was the next
teen thing and he wasn't going anywhere
and he's gonna be in this long string of
movies where he played the drunk friend
like in 21 and over with this movie at
last year's the spectacular now he has
really shown to me that he has a lot of
talents especially on the drums he's
been Drummond apparently since he was
age 15 so he really was perfect for this
role however JK Simmons in this movie is
an absolute revelation imagine if j
jonah Jameson shaved off his head
became a music instructor and got really
vulgar that's his character in this
movie and he's brilliant he gives one of
the best performances I've seen so far
this year he's totally Oscar worthy you
know all those YouTube montage videos of
best movie insults you could take his
character in this movie and fill the
runtime of all of those videos with the
things he comes up with but what's so
beautiful about this movie is the drive
that tellers character feels that desire
to want to be good the passion that he
feels for a subject that he is so
incredibly excited about but he has a
hard time communicating that to his
family his father played by Paul Reiser
because it's a really hard thing to
express I personally know all about that
and I completely connect with that
aspect of his character because I had
the same type of childhood I had a
really hard time convincing others of my
love of movies and trying to get them to
understand and appreciate what I saw in
them
a really difficult thing to do when
you're younger is express your love of
an art form because everyone else around
you just wants you to work in a factory
or become a football player or get a job
in an office or something traditional it
takes that rare parent to understand the
love of art and that's portrayed
beautifully in this film but the
highlight by far is the butting of heads
between teller and Simmons this is an
all accounts a psychological film it's
not just a music film it's not
entertaining and funny this is a very
serious psychological battle between two
people who feel so strongly about their
positions and their opinions and to see
them clash is some of the most intense
acting that I've seen in a movie this
year I'm not going to give anything away
but this film I think contains my
favorite ending of the entire year it
has the most emotionally powerful last
10 minutes I've seen so far in 2014
whiplash is an incredible film if you're
a fan of music check it out if you are a
fan of art and you have a hard time
expressing your love of art see it if
you are a fan of great acting definitely
check this movie out whiplash is one of
the best films of the year and it gets
an A+ my second film of the year to get
an A+ I'm so excited that I'm finally
seeing some really good movies towards
the end of the year definitely check out
Birdman - that was my other one I'm also
a humongous fan of jazz music and I
really like the idea of young kids
discovering their love of jazz and
trying to work through that and all the
emotional Heights that come with that if
you also are similar to me in that
respect I would definitely check out the
anime kids on the slope it's directed by
shin and Shara Watanabe director of
cowboy bebop and samurai champloo it's
similar to whiplash in a lot of ways I
would definitely check this out of you
haven't seen it yet speaking of anime
I'm very excited to announce that I am
partnering with crunchyroll to bring you
guys more anime entertainment
crunchyroll contacted me and they would
like me to tell you guys about what
they're offering right now and that is
30 days of their service for free with
their premium subscription you get no
ads amazing video quality and it's only
695 a month but if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris stuckman you
can get 30 days for free a free trial
but I
about crunchyroll is that it was created
by fans of anime to preserve the quality
of anime and to show it respect the
typical offer is 14 days but through me
you can get 30 days crunchyroll is
offering this exclusively to you guys so
definitely check that out if you feel
like cancelling you can but I have
promised you guys that I would bring you
guys more anime reviews in the future
and I definitely plan on doing that so
definitely check out crunchyroll.com
slash Chris stuckman they have kids on
the slope on there as well just like I
mentioned thank you so much as always
for watching and I would like to know
you guys did think of whiplash or kids
on the slope if you have seen it because
there are very similar themes in both of
them guys thank you so much as always
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Benoist